لا تخترق بيومينج بهذه الصواريخ حواجز
رياح التوتر العالمي فقط لكنها تتخطى خطوط
المالوف بكثير
باتجاه البحر او على مقربه من حدود جارتها
لا فرق استفزاز مثل واستفزاز فما تريده
كوريا الشماليه ليس فقط اختبار وتحسين
تقنيتها الخاصه بالاسلحه بل ارسال رساله
سياسيه الى العالم فهي تريد ان تقول ان
العقوبات لن تمنع تطوير اسلحتها وتاتي
ايضا ردا على كل مناوره تجريها الولايات
المتحده وجارتها الجنوبيه واليابان كما
تريد كوريا الشماليه تحقيق مكاسب لها في
ظل انشغال العالم بحرب روسيا واوكرانيا
فيما يرى مراقبون ان وراء تصيد الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي المستمر تهيئه الارض لخطوه
اكثر استفزازا
اختبار سلاح نووي للمره الاولى في خمس
سنوات او حتى شنه هجوم محدود النطاق على
كوريا الجنوبيه اما داخليا اثاره اعجاب
الشعب وتعزيز الولاء للنظام الحاكم هدف
اخر لبيوميا
الصعيد من غير مسبوق ووسط اوراق تحالفات
يشهدها العالم تتشكل لكنها قد تتبعثر حاله
تحول تلك المناورات الى حرب حقيقيه على
الارض
عصام عبد السلام العربيه